joining me now is an old friend Brian
kilcamas professional dog trainer and
owner of Great Dogs Brian who's to blame
here this seems to be a bit of a pattern
with the owning of these Shepherds at
the White House and the bidens
I think there are a couple of issues
Laura by the way it's great seeing you
it's been a long time one the training
I'm a little bit confused about because
it doesn't seem like the dog has had the
proper foundation work to respond to
command two as soon as that dog bit he
should have been put in a muzzle
you know he's in a difficult situation
and the Secret Service people are not
relaxed people and dogs read our body
language and when he see these guys
holding themselves and coming up
assertively or surprising him he's
reacting to it so the first thing I
would do is muzzle him two what I work
off of when I work with aggressive dogs
I assume the worst if I assume the worst
it doesn't happen but dogs getting out
being off lead and not being responsive
to Direction
is impossible to really direct the dog's
behavior and correcting aggression makes
it worse
well even Biden's dog lives above the
law on this White House Brian watch
D.C Municipal rules after a dog bites an
individual the dog must be quarantined
for 10 days do you know if Commander was
quarantined I have to create the Secret
Service you know my team and I kind of
did a bet to see how many times I would
get questions on Commander
and it's kind of laughing it off Brian
but you got 10 dog bites in four months
10.
right and they need to get some
professional help in there and make a
decision on whether that dog can adjust
to living in the white house and all the
distractions and confusion that goes on
or he can't be allowed in there but the
first thing I do is there's what is
called the Baskerville muzzle it's the
most Humane muzzle they can eat they can
drink and that dog should be muzzled
until they get it under control Brian
there are a lot of people in DC who need
the Baskerville muzzle as well so I'm
going to be getting a lot of those
a lot of those the first lady really
quickly Brian is saying that there's
going to be new leashing protocol put in
place new leashing protocol she calls it
does that make you feel better about
this dog
I'm not sure I know what that means as
far as leasing protocol being uh where
he will not be let off the lead or he'll
be taught to walk on a loose lead and
take direction as far as when you pull
up in that picture you see the tension
on the lead
that runs down the lead to the dog so if
somebody comes up he may react to it so
it's really teaching both owners and the
dog as far as how to behave lots of
quarantining needs to be done Brian I
knew you'd have the answers great to see
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else